where did that voice come from
uh that voice i tried out on my kids and
it made them laugh so that's the one i
used that that was really that was it
because in this you play your own twin i
play the twin brother as well it does
sound subtly different
it's a more
it is a more it's it's him with hair
it's a more a bulient version of him
it's he's much lighter
groot kind of sounds like this and oh
there's my brother i hate him and drew
his brother is so excited
that's basically the thing he's so
tiring to do that for a day
but but it's not your first kind of
middle european accent didn't you do one
for audition oh i did an audition for
the dana carvey show where i did a bit
called uh
the uh the german who says nice things
so he would
so i i
i don't know
i thought it would be funny to just
stand in front of people and yell things
do the german accent i think one of them
was
let's all pile into the minivan and get
some frozen yogurt
it was a pleasure babysitting kevin
you're not getting older you are getting
better
[Applause]
those new year's reviews so we thought
we might ask our audience right for the
highlights
of their year
and then we could throw back to you guys
who could do them like news headlines oh
okay so for instance so so christine
what was the highlight of your year oh
gosh um
not getting shingles
that didn't happen
i don't know uh
you know watching my uh
daughter sing
jingle bells
over and over again okay and then the
headline would be
actress pretends not to be bored by
child
[Applause]
hello jingles goodbye shingles
all right
i'm going to go i'm going to go into the
crowd now and sit and see see what's
happened to people so uh
oh look you and your christmas
jumper now i'm sensing this man that's
had a fascinating year
older sorry it's a danish name oh
marvelous
danish name scandinavia is represented
tonight so it's lovely old older all the
only arbiters only only older already
oola oola oh look irish for apple okay
what's been the highlight of your year
oola what have you behind out of my head
yeah
not much is happening no
let's go to let's go back to will in the
newsroom
[Music]
no memory of 2013.
let me do
this lady here hello
hi
what's your name kate kate lovely and
what's what's been the big event in your
year kate um
i actually got over my phobia of eggs
were you working with a therapist
no there was alcohol involved
so you got drunk and had an egg
okay let's go to the newsroom where
steve will report on kate getting over a
fear of eggs
young woman named kate is beautiful and
i am getting a divorce
[Applause]
let's do one more hello sir what's your
name
my name is says sir what's your name my
name is sev sev yeah
[Music]
who's on the phone
what's been the highlight of your your
year seth it's got to be uh
me and my girlfriend you're all loved up
i love that
[Music]
girlfriend are you living together not
yet but next year
so what happened it just happened no
we've been uh we've been best of friends
for
i'd say three three and a half years and
then i moved to london
yes and then
and then you
no got drunk
oh wow that we realized our love for
each other
that's lovely
[Applause]
uh i moved to london in april
it's all happened today april
what's you what's your name by the way
nicole nicole seven nicole
so
let's go back to uh will in the newsroom
for the headlines on sev and nicole
sev
and nicole find new love
let's just hope she doesn't have a fear
of eggs
and are you going to do the whole
would
this is cheap and tacky this is awful
this is like the jeremy kyle show
unless you wanted to you can do it if
you want to
if you want to
[Applause]
nicole
you're my best friend
you're the other half of me
i'll just go get something out my sock
now
[Applause]
and therefore
i can see it here coming i can see it
here
comes up closer
[Music]
[Applause]
will you marry me
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations
thank
[Applause]
you hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
go to the wedding now you look lovely
paul thank you i'm here to promote the
new wes anderson
woman woman robbed at graham norton's
show
so here you are in a film about a man
with dolls and of course you to your
work have become dolls uh there you are
from uh the office
oh
yeah lovely
then what else have we got we've got you
from uh
anchorman i think you've heard without
the glasses there you are from anchorage
that is a really good
dog killed the guy look at that that's
uncanny
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then oh little groove oh
let's grow look at me
hey everybody
it's a little tiny me i keep in my own
pocket
[Applause]
happily married now uh steve but it
sounds like the wooing of your wife
it was quite problematic it wasn't all
plain sailing uh no i i didn't sweep her
off her feet
uh she she worked i worked at a theater
called second city in chicago and she
worked across the street uh and and was
taking classes there at the time and she
was actually one of my students in one
of the classes i was teaching there and
she worked across the street so after
the shows i used to go across and say
hello and sit at the bar and
to try desperately to strike up a
conversation
and the after months and months and
months of doing this i finally thought i
had the courage to ask her out and i
said
you know if i were to ever ask someone
out that person would probably be
a person like you
and her response was well if a guy like
you were to ask someone like me out and
it was just like
you could tell everyone around us was
like shut up and do it
you're making us sick
and finally we ended up going out and
that was
23 years ago
steve you've had experience being
knocked out haven't you yes yes i have
but not in a fight no i i played ice
hockey and i was a goalie and i got hit
with a puck and was knocked out
we were up in canada playing a team up
there and
when you when you go when you travel
you tend to stay at someone else's house
like the you know the other goalies
family i saved their family
um so they their family ran out onto the
ice to see if i was okay said steve
steve what's my name and i had no idea
what his name was
that's funny
and they and i said i don't know they're
like oh my god
but yeah it was the same thing it was
like just a headache headache right neck
whiplash and it was it was pretty it was
a little fuzzy dude and the fact that
you were lying there saying i hope they
got it that is a testament to you as a
person hate it babe because that's what
it becomes it's like oh man i just died
but i hope they got the shot exactly i
hope it looked good because i can't do
it again
this is my last one i can
[Applause]
like what are do doing
i don't i see no problem with that
are you about 20 years old there yeah
what was going on in your head i wanted
to look like magnum p.i
i actually grew a mustache in high
school because i played lacrosse and i
thought it would make me look more
threatening
and it didn't really it just made me
look like a porn star
a porn performer
that's an important star is it
he was in it he wasn't the star
he's a date player
david
he was at the other side of the pool
away from the action
[Music]
you